[Musique]
deux objets ne peuvent jamais occuper le
même
espace au même
moment le virage vient à
vous vous traversez peut-être une crise
[Musique]
d'identité suis-je un athlète
un
[Musique]
compétiteur si tu montes dans une de mes
voitures tu le fais pour
gagner il est trop
l tu es au bord de la faillite comment
ça se fait tu dépenses plus que tu
gagnes
alors je fais quoi remporte
les tu devras mettre la clé s la
porte c'est une arme pointé sur
têtes tu devrais me céder le contrôle de
tes
actions je dois avoir toutes les cartes
en bien j'ai la moitié des ces
en nous sommes tous des
coururs
notre terrible Jo tu pens pouir revenir
bientôt je peux rester loin de
[Musique]
toiie alors
VO tu étais censé sauver tu m'as promis
qu'il n'alla pas mourir le père
dans
deux objets ne peuvent jamais occuper le
même
espace au même
moment
Enzo va leur montrer qu'il plus
[Musique]
fort